hey guys it's alex so you know i love
cheese
more specifically queso and i've been
hearing a lot of hype about chipotle's
new
queso blanco and how good it is so you
know
i have to try to recreate it all right
let's cook
so to help recreate this recipe i
checked out chipotle's website
they listed out all 13 real ingredients
for their queso blanco
and i pretty much have them all we've
got aged monterey jack white
cheddar tomatoes peppers onions garlic
this is some legit queso all right we're
going to start with prepping our
ingredients
first i'm going to mince up a clove of
garlic next i'm going to mix up our
onion now i'm going to dice up our
tomato so we're gonna get right into our
peppers
i love a little kick in my queso first
up poblano
a lot of dyson in this recipe
and next is a serrano pepper this will
also give us some
good heat i just want to be careful not
to touch your eyes during this part
beautiful so now for the main event
we're going to grate the cheese
starting with our aged monterey jack so
i actually read online that the dairy
used in making
the aged monterey jack cheese is sourced
from
small family farms in wisconsin you
don't even have to go to wisconsin to
get your cheese
just go to chipotle all right i think
we're good on our monterey
jack and now of course because this is
queso blanco we're gonna be using white
cheddar
all right cheddar is looking good i'm
getting hungry now
all right all of our ingredients are
prepped it's time to make the queso so
i'm gonna start with my pot over
medium-low heat
and i'm going to add milk and heavy
cream
our garlic and salt give that a mix
all right it's starting to bubble so i'm
going to start adding in our cheese
i'm not going to add it in all at once
i'm making sure all the cheese is melted
before i add in the next batch
already getting that melty cheese action
all right i'm gonna add in the rest of
our cheese now
our cheese is fully melted down into the
milk now looks really good
i'm gonna move on to our corn starch
slurry this is gonna help
thicken up our queso so just some corn
starch and water and i'm gonna whisk
this up first
and then pour that right into our cheese
mixture all right our queso is looking
nice and thick
i'm gonna go ahead and add in the rest
of our ingredients and this will
continue to thicken so we've got our
tomato
our onion our poblano pepper our serrano
pepper
and our chipotle powder so i'm just
gonna cook this down for a couple more
minutes
and then we'll be ready to go all right
our queso is looking really good
oh smells even better the peppers and
the cheeses are really coming through
all right the moment of truth
it's super creamy super smooth just the
right amount of kick
for the quickest way to enjoy chipotle's
new queso blanco
get it delivered by using the chipotle
app oh yes